On your way to retrieve the Lotus of the Palace,
you journey through the Sunken Valley, a place that's inaccessible to most.
In it coils a white serpent, an old god of the land.
It's worshipped by the Sunken Valley Clan, a forlorn people who man the Gunfort.
Deeper still, you'll find the valley where the monkeys dwell,
where the Sculptor trained to become a shinobi.
He trained with a partner here, named Kingfisher,
a woman who would go on to be consumed by an undying ape.
The lore runs deep here.
Let's talk about it.
This is the Great Serpent.
A god of the land, or so the Sunken Valley Clan believe.
They don't just worship the snake;
rather, they worship the heart,
for the heart is believed to be where one's spirit resides.
They enshrine the organs,
believing that they represent the deity itself,
and with two hearts
you can initiate the Dragon's Return ending,
an ending that has the Divine Child of the Rejuvenating Waters become a cradle for the Dragon's Blood,
which allows the Sakura Dragon to leave Japan.
For when the Sakura Dragon came from the West and took root in Ashina,
many lesser gods left,
and the Serpent God was almost certainly one of them.
Look ahead to Mibu Village for proof.
Here, we find scraps of snake skin
caught upon rooftops and dangling from the gates,
and it may not have just been the Serpent God that left this place;
Buddha, too, has been desecrated here as a result of the Sakura Dragon.
Furthermore,
just as snake statues are found all throughout Senpou Temple,
so too are Buddha statues found within the Sunken Valley,
home of the Serpent God.
These statues seem like they were intended to hold the two hearts of the Great Serpents.
The first statue is cradling a snake skin,
which likely belonged to the full-grown snake just beyond.
The second heart, however, lies in a cave.
Toxic Memorial Mob: "You there.
Don't go into that cave up ahead.
Inside is an old shrine, where the Serpent God dwells,
and if the Serpent God swallows you...
...you can't buy any more offerings, now, can you?"
This dried heart might have belonged to an older serpent,
a spirit that was passed from Buddha's hands to ours,
so that we can pursue the Dragon's Return.
Food for thought.
So, those are the Serpent God's hearts,
but what about its eyes?
The Snake Eyes are the commanders of the Sunken Valley Clan,
female fighters equipped with flint cannons and blessed with phenomenal vision.
As the Eyes of the Snake,
they've positioned themselves at both entrances to the Sunken Valley,
striking fear into any stranger who approaches,
and not only do they watch out for the snake,
those of the Sunken Valley also offer themselves to it in "marriage".
Well, "marriage" in quotation marks, because it really means "to make an offering of oneself",
such is their devotion to the Serpent God.
But when they're not feeding themselves to a snake,
it's likely that the Sunken Valley Clan is busy mining the precious metals of the Valley.
Magnetic deposits are found all over the Valley,
and their value is evident,
for the Sunken Valley Clan ended up concocting medicines to help them resist the toxic state of this place,
and while it's said that those who stay here long enough can overcome their weakness to poison,
two prominent women here are still devastated by it.
These are the Snake Eyes,
commanders of the clan,
and they are no match for Sabimaru, your poisonous prosthetic kodachi blade,
and there's a reason for this,
for the blade reads,
"Sabimaru was wielded in wars of old,
and is a national treasure of Ashina.
It was once used to drive off the inhuman Okami warrior women,
and even now, it is likely to be effective against their descendants."
The Snake Eyes are descendants of the ancient Okami Clan.
"Okami" means "Dragon",
and it's likely referring to the clan of carp-like beings that you find in Fountainhead Palace,
because long, long ago,
in the most ancient days of the Ashina,
this Okami Clan gathered the Fountainhead Fragrance
and arrived at the Palace.
They pledged themselves to the Sakura Serpent,
making ceremonial blood offerings to it,
which is an act that is not unlike what the Sunken Valley Clan did.
They, too, offer themselves in "marriage" to the Serpent God;
the difference is while one Clan dances joyously in a Divine Realm,
the other Clan sits sullenly atop the frozen, poisonous cliff face of the Sunken Valley.
One incredibly neat detail is that the Okami warrior women are master marksmen;
they have this godlike accuracy with the bow, lightning bolt and...
...soccer ball?
Just so, their descendants, too, can also hit their targets from half a league away,
still using ranged weapons just like their ancestors,
except now ones that have been adapted for the modern age.
There are some benefits to being left behind, it seems,
and that's a point of contention:
whether they were left behind or not,
and it's something I've found myself going back and forth on the entire time I've been scripting this.
There are two options that I see,
and the question is this:
was the Sunken Valley Clan left behind when the rest of their Clan ascended,
staying loyal to the Serpent God
whereas the Okami went on to worship the Sakura Dragon?
Or did the Okami ascend to the Divine Realm
and then return,
with some serpent-worshipping descendants
going on to settle in the Sunken Valley?
And make no mistake: the Okami Clan did eventually come back - that is a fact - after they ascended to the Divine Realm.
They brought the thunder with them,
invading Ashina and killing its people.
The game calls this "an old war";
it's a long-forgotten event, so
it's no surprise that the details are scarce.
We don't even know why they invaded.
I'm curious to hear your thoughts.
But what we do know is that the Okami were eventually repelled
by Sabimaru,
an heirloom forged by the Ashina.
This weapon held the poisonous gift of blue rust,
which was Kryptonite to the Okami warriors.
The context of this war changes, dependent on whether you believe that
the Sunken Valley Clan was left behind when the Okami ascended,
or whether you believe that the Sunken Valley Clan came to exist
after the Okami invaded, and descended from the Fountainhead.
There's evidence for both ideas;
I can't find one piece of evidence that makes it true beyond reason,
so, I'll tell you both stories, and you can decide what to believe.
So first,
the Sunken Valley Clan may have come to exist as a result
of the Okamis' failed invasion.
The Green Mossy Gourd says that it was "made out of necessity
by those who made poisonous lands their home."
It's said that if you live there long enough, eventually poison won't affect you at all.
If the Okami were indeed bitter at being defeated by poison,
then perhaps they wished to overcome this weakness over generations of exposure.
Alternatively, it's also fair to believe that the Sunken Valley Clan was left behind by the Okami Clan
when they ascended to the Divine Realm.
If this was the case, then they would have learned about their weakness to poison
from living in the Valley all this time,
and they may have helped the Ashina forge Sabimaru
when the Okami came back and invaded.
Sabimaru was "gifted" with poisonous blue rust, after all,
and there is evidence of an alliance between the Sunken Valley Clan and Ashina;
many of the Sunken Valley man the watchtowers of the Ashina,
and the key to their Gunfort Shrine is  even kept in the private quarters of the Ashina Elite.
Together, the Ashina and the Sunken Valley Clan may well have repelled the inhuman Okami.
I like this theory more.
The Ashina called the Okami Clan "inhuman"
and while you would assume that that means that they
invaded in their carp-like state,
they may not have,
for Sabimaru calls them "spirits",
and this scroll of an old battle calls them "ghosts".
"Ghosts once lurked the lands of Ashina.
The Ghosts' lightning was of the Fountainhead gods,
unstoppable by normal means."
Whatever the case, the ancient Ashina were besieged by their lightning,
and so, in addition to Sabimaru, which was an offensive tool,
they actually developed a few measures as well.
First was the Art of Lightning Reversal,
and there's a guide to how to perform it hung in their dojo
where their warriors train,
and second was something called "Eel Livers".
Eels are relatives of dragons,
and they allowed the Ashina to suppress the lightning,
the force of the gods.
Though admittedly, this didn't work for very long.
This drug is littered throughout Ashina Castle,
and they even offered it ceremoniously
at a couple of shrines.
It's this remnant of an ancient war against the Okami.
It's no surprise then that, given all of this,
the Ashina did come to consider lightning powers as "heretical":
Genichiro names them as such,
when he invokes the name of his master, Tomoe.
Genichiro: "I will seize any manner of heretical strength."
Tomoe was also of the Okami;
she descended via the "Floating Passage",
and she was this benevolent being who
decided to live amongst the Ashina.
Reflective of her Clan,
she likely taught Genichiro how to use that bow of his,
and she also taught him the Lightning Arts that
he would go to practice fervently.
She would eventually sacrifice everything
for a boy named Takeru,
a boy cursed with the Dragon's Heritage,
but that story Is one for another time.
We follow the notes that Tomoe and Takeru left us,
and they, in turn,
are following the knowledge that was left by Tomoe's relatives,
the Okami clan, when they first ascended to the Divine Realm.
This is knowledge that guides us towards the Fountainhead Fragrance,
which requires us to obtain the Lotus of the Palace,
which grows where the Fountainhead Waters pool deeply.
On our way to said Lotus, we travel through the Bodhisattva Valley,
the place where the monkeys dwell,
and fruits hidden by monkeys in tree hollows can sometimes ferment and turn into sake,
with a bit of luck.
Sculptor: *drinks, coughs* "It burns the throat, same as ever.
This really brings back memories.
I trained in the techniques of the Shinobi, in the Valley where the monkeys dwelled..."
Sekiro: "By yourself?"
Sculptor: "...No.
There were two of us.
We were rogue Shinobi...
...there was no proper master for the likes of us.
That's why we went to the Valley:
to run, to jump, to clash swords...
...where one slip would mean your doom.
That was how we trained.
We came to move exactly as monkeys did after a time... *drinks*
I drank this Monkey Booze whenever I tired of training,
and I'd listen to the howl of my partner's whistling finger while I drank.
Whistling through that ring would fill the Valley with a somber melody.
Strangely enough, I enjoyed that sound..."
The Sculptor's partner was called Kingfisher,
the name that was etched onto her ring.
Her cry could once be heard all along the waterfront of the Sunken Valley,
and her whistle could be used to drive beasts wild.
Speaking of which...
This is the Guardian Ape,
sitting in the cove where the Fountainhead Waters pool.
It's cultivating this Lotus to give to its mate,
for the Ape actually lost his previous partner,
whose corpse you find hidden away in an alcove.
It's been so long since he lost her, though,
that even the flowers offered in tribute to her passing
have withered to dust.
For the Ape is immortal;
this is thanks to the Centipede, which emerges when you sever the Ape's head
using this gigantic sword that
likely once belonged to the Sculptor's training partner, the Kingfisher.
It's an incredible weapon, but it's no Mortal Blade,
and within the immortal Ape's belly, we find the Kingfisher's ring.
Sculptor: "What's that you have there?
Where did you get that finger?"
Sekiro: "The Guardian Ape of the Sunken Valley.
I found it in his belly."
Sculptor: "I see...
...to think it was in the belly of an ape...
...I'm sure it will play a somber, but enjoyable tune.
Make sure you use it well."
If she is indeed dead,
then the loss of this woman could have been what first led
the Sculptor to become Shura,
for when the Sculptor turns again at the end of the game,
you can use the Kingfisher's ring to play a somber tune.
A weeping voice, full of solitude and beauty,
somber enough to temporarily quell a voice of rage.
With the Kingfisher avenged, we can claim the Lotus of the Palace,
putting us one step closer to the Fountainhead Fragrance.
Next, we travel to Ashina Depths,
to this bottomless hole,
to the Hidden Forest,
and to Mibu Village.
Remember to hit the notification bell, so you don't miss when the video goes live,
and I'll see you next time.